well hello everyone and welcome to
today's webinar on dot culture
and the impact of pre-analytics and
challenges faced by nursing
my name is Stefan bosha I'm a medical
Affairs manager with integrated
diagnostic Solutions here at BD Canada
and I will be your moderator for today's
events
so today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by BD
um so we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
may have uh during the presentation so
to do so
just simply type them into the um ask a
question box and don't forget to click
Send
um and we'll answer as many questions as
we have
um time to
um uh time four at the end of the the
presentation so you may also submit any
technical issues uh here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the the
presentations someone will help you um
to fix that
um so now I'd like to uh welcome our
speakers today so our first speaker is
Dr Patrick Murray who was the former uh
vice president worldwide microbiology
for BD life sciences
um Dr Marie received his uh doctorate
degree in microbiology at UCLA and
postgraduate training in clinical
microbiology at the Mayo Clinic in
Rochester Minnesota
he was director of the clinical
microbiology Laboratories at a Barnes
Jewish Hospital and a professor of
medicine and pathology at Washington
University from 1976 to 1999. in 1999 Dr
Murray joined the faculty of the
University of Maryland School of
Medicine
and in 2001 he accepted the position of
senior scientists and chief of
microbiology at the National Institute
of Health
in 2011 he retired from the National
Institute and accepted his position at
BD until he retired in 2022. Dr Murray
is a fellow of the American Academy of
microbiology and the Infectious Disease
Society of America
he was a former chairman of the American
Board of medical and microbiology
editor-in-chief of the manual of
clinical microbiology
an editor of the journal of clinical
microbiology Dr Murray has authored more
than 300 research articles and 21 books
our second speaker is Sarah smes who has
several years of nursing experience with
a specialization in vascular access she
is a registered nurse and holds a
master's in nursing education her
nursing career includes experience in
oncology infusion therapy Home Care
vascular access education teaching
mentorship and Leadership roles in
Ontario California and Washington
Washington State
she is a member of the ins the
association of vascular access as well
as the Siva Association she is an
oncology certified nurse and is
certified with national vascular access
associations in both Canada and the
United States
Sarah is well versed with vascular
access products and the patient's
experience related to their use and
practice she has provided training and
support for clinicians throughout her
career and she is eager to facilitate
others in their learning while focusing
on quality patient care and positive
outcomes
evidence informed practice
drives her to assist others with the
Improvement of practice and safety and
the development of efficient workflow in
a complex Healthcare environment
so now without uh further Ado I will
leave the floor to Dr Murray for his
presentation
thank you Stefan for your your
introduction and uh I want to thank BD
for the opportunity to speak to this
group today
um I as Stefan said I retired the
beginning of this year
so I'm always pleased that BD remembers
who I am and invites me back uh for
opportunity to speak to various groups
today I'm going to talk about sepsis and
specifically
diagnostic challenges that were
confronted with with sepsis
now I think it's important maybe this is
sort of the educator in me the startup
definition so that we're all on the same
page
um we we're all talking about the same
thing or thinking about the same things
so a bloodstream infection is when you
have a positive blood culture and a
patient with systemic signs of infection
and thus infection may be either primary
that is originated in the bloodstream or
it may be secondary originating from a
distant organ like the lungs or the
urinary tract
when we talk about sepsis it's the next
stage in a bloodstream infection and
that is when we have a life-threatening
organ dysfunction that's caused by
dysregulated host response to infection
maybe a little bit more clearly to say
is if the body overreacts to an
infection it could damage an organ and
that leads to sepsis as we know it and
septic shock is a more advanced stage of
this where multiple organs are affected
um primarily because the blood pressure
is reduced patient is in shock and we
have inadequate perfusion of blood and
oxygen to the various organs obviously
aseptic shock condition is the most
serious of what we're dealing with
and I think it's also important to think
about a few statistics excuse me
now
in the data that I'm showing in this
slide this originated from data that was
collected for the year 2017 and what
they estimated globally there was almost
50 million cases of sepsis that occurred
every year and those resulted in
approximately 11 million deaths or 20
percent of all deaths that were reported
sepsis is the leading cause of mortality
and critical illness worldwide with
Hospital mortality rates roughly in the
range of 25 to 30 percent and obviously
there are risk factors that impact on
that death rate such as increasing age
immune dysfunction delays in the receipt
of appropriate antimicrobials and the
organs that are injured during septic
shock clinical studies have demonstrated
also there's a two-fold increase in
mortality when sepsis is caused in when
sepsis is managed with inappropriate
antimicrobial therapy and this really
underscores the importance of
Diagnostics to be able to make a very
specific diagnosis of what organism is
responsible for sepsis and what
antibiotics that organism is susceptible
to
otherwise we treat the patient
empirically in the risk of inappropriate
antimicrobial therapy is significant
and if we put a cost figure on this if
we look in the United States it's
estimated that septic patients and
hospitalization of those septic patients
costs more than 24 billion dollars each
year so as the rate of sepsis increase
the cost of sepsis increases it has a
dramatic impact on the hospital system
if we look closer to home in Canada it
was estimated that there are
approximately 100
000 cases of sepsis each year
16
000 patients died each year from sepsis
and the cost is between forty two
thousand and sixty six thousand dollars
for each septic patient
so as we look both in regionally as well
as globally sepsis is common sepsis is
deadly and sepsis is very expensive
now as we think about the septic sepsis
guidelines or the management of septic
patients that were published last year
key components are the early
identification of a patient with
suspected sepsis
to measure lactate and other parameters
that can assess the uh the risk of
sepsis in these patients to perform
cultures and I I emphasize cultures here
because this diagnostic test is the most
specific one for predicting what
organism is responsible for sepsis and
what antibiotics can be used for
treatment
the use of antibiotics and fluid should
be initiated early in the course in
order to maximize
our success and being able to manage
these patients
now what I want to do is quote and I
don't usually read quotations but I'm
going to do it for this one slide
the 2021 sepsis guidelines and I'm doing
this because they make a very important
point
they differentiate the patient's
clinical condition and say based on the
patient's clinical condition that should
dictate when we start antimicrobials so
we recommend appropriate routine
microbiologic cultures including blood
cultures should be obtained before
starting antimicrobial therapy in
patients with suspected sepsis and
septic shock
but it's very important here if it
results in no substantial delay in the
start of antimicrobials
so we for the patients that are clearly
septic or in septic shock the most
important thing we do is start the
antimicrobials
now in 28 to 63 percent of patients they
receive antibiotics prior to culture and
I'll show you in the next Slide the
impact of that
the microbiologic cultures must be
weighed against mortality risk
for the mortality risk of delayed key
therapy in these patients
now if we look at the
impact of antibiotics on positive
cultures I think this is a very
important slide this was a study that
was done a couple of years ago and they
collected almost 1500 blood cultures and
they looked at the percent of those
blood cultures that were positive and
they looked also at when the patients
were started on antibiotics
the patients that were started on
antibiotics
before the blood cultures were collected
had a 50 reduction in positive blood
cultures so if you look at the first
bars anywhere from -6 up to one hour
after antibiotics were started we have
roughly a 25 to 30 percent positive
blood cultures
but after antibiotics were started for
more than one hour we see a significant
reduction in positive plug cultures and
this emphasizes the fact that when we
collect a blood culture it becomes
really important to try to do that
before the antibiotics are started and
again now if a patient's in sepsis or
septic shock then we may not be able to
do that but we also eventually keep in
mind what is a negative blood culture
mean in a patient where the blood
coaches are collected after antibiotics
were started
if we look again now at this the
surviving sepsis guidelines uh what was
specifically recommended
for adults with possible septic shocker
High likelihood sepsis we recommend
administering antimicrobials immediately
and ideally within one hour of
recognition
so they want to start the antibiotics
very rapidly
for patients with possible sepsis
without shock we recommend a rapid
assessment of the likelihood of
infectious versus non-infectious causes
of the acute illness
and a Time limited course of Rapid
investigation and if specific concern
for infection persists
the administration of animal cruels
within three hours from the time when
sepsis was first recognized
and then finally with adults with a low
likelihood of infection and without
shock
we suggest deferring antimicrobials
while continuing to closely monitor the
patient so again using the clinical
condition of the patient to decide when
you start antimicrobials becomes very
important and for all of these patients
if infection is suspected the try to
collect the cultures as quickly as
possible
now let me pose a couple of questions
what are the most common sources of
sepsis
what microbiologic specimens have the
highest diagnostic yield
and what are the challenges in
collecting the microbiology specimens
now sepsis can be caused by infections
with bacteria
fungi viruses and parasites so all
infectious organisms can cause sepsis
infections associated with sepsis
include the urinary tract lower
respiratory tract
meningitis intra-abdominal infections
skin and soft tissue infections and
intravascular or catheter-related
infections
now if you think about it
most of our cultures are geared to
detect bacteria
and geared to detect yeast
so filament is fungi viruses and
parasites are likely not going to be
detected by our conventional cultures
and so as we think about positive
cultures it's important to keep that in
mind and again let me illustrate that a
little bit
it's not uncommon to hear the comments
that blood cultures are frequently
negative in my septic patient
and data that's been collected would say
that can be anywhere from 20 to 48
percent of the blood cultures will be
positive so as much as 80 percent of the
blood coaches are negative I already
Illustrated in the earlier slide that
the effective antibiotics can directly
reduce the number of positive blood
cultures but we also have to think about
other things like viruses so as an
example we've we're in I'm not sure if
I'd say in the midst of the covert
pandemic hopefully we're getting beyond
that it's becoming
um something that we've we're learning
to live with but we saw with covert that
virus can cause sepsis and so again you
have to keep in mind not all causes the
sepsis are what we can culture with
routine blood cultures I think it's also
important to think about we can get
other positive blood cultures that can
help up with the diagnosis whether
that's from a urine culture respiratory
culture or whatever but there will still
be a certain proportion of cultures that
are negative and as we Face a diagnostic
challenge what we want to say is that
for the organisms responsible for sepsis
that we should be able to culture
let's maximize our ability to do that
so let's talk about this just a little
bit if we look at different types of
specimens they can be collected a
urinary tract
specimens are become very are very
important in a septic patient you would
a physician routinely will do would be
to collect blood cultures but also
respiratory cultures urine cultures and
other specimens where where infections
are suspected
in urinary tract there usually is a low
urine flow rate in septic patients so
that becomes a challenge
in addition the number of organisms per
milliliter urine is affected by the type
of pathogen the time of day that it's
collected the frequency that the patient
has been voiding whether the patient is
hydrated or not and prior antimicrobial
therapy and it's those various factors
that have really underscored the the
observation that more than half of
patients with urinary tract infections
have less than 10 to the five organisms
per milliliter of urine so in many cases
where the urinary tract infection
particularly a septic patient there may
be small numbers of organisms that are
actually present in the specimen that's
collected and also for urinary tract
infection where you want to avoid
contamination with urethral bacteria
for lower respiratory tract infections
we have to think about fastidious
organisms that may not be recovered in
blood cultures viral pathogens and then
contamination with oral secretions
for meningitis this is an invasive
collection so it's more difficult prior
exposure to antibiotics can reduce the
value of culture and if the infection is
caused by viruses or fungi like
cryptococcus the coaches are typically
negative
intra-abdominal infections or invasive
collection with a mixture of organisms
and the same is true for skin and soft
tissue infections
for an intravascular infection many
pathogens will not be recovered in the
blood culture as I've already mentioned
care has to be used to avoid
contamination
the majority of bacterial infections
have small numbers of organisms present
I'll share some data on that
positive blood cultures are really
related to the types of media that we
use much so more so than what instrument
the cultures are incubated in
and finally the presence of antibiotics
reduce the culture yield
so as we think about blood cultures and
that's going to be my focus now for the
remainder of this presentation
there are two factors two variables that
are most important one is the volume of
blood that's collected and the second is
the culture media that's used
if we think about optimizing our blood
cultures in the pre-analytical phase
there's some important points that are
important to keep in mind
most septic patients have less than one
organism per milliliter of blood
on the average most blood culture
bottles are filled with less than 25
percent of the recommended volume of
blood
numerous clinical studies have
demonstrated that if the bottles were
properly filled the proportion of
positive blood cultures would be
increased by almost 50 percent
and finally clinical studies have
demonstrated that two to three blood
cultures each consisting of two bottles
would ye give us an Optimum yield for
those flood cultures
now let me share a little bit of
Statistics a little bit of data that
supports each of these
the first is the quantitation of
bacteremia and funimi and I've quoted
here five studies
um there are numerous studies that show
the same thing but I just want to
emphasize uh one very important point if
we look at the last column and I have a
list of different organisms staph aureus
E coli pseudomonas yeast and so forth
in the mid in the vast
how do I freeze this in a large
proportion of these bacteremias there is
less than one organism present anywhere
from about 25 percent to over 70 percent
of the cultures had fewer than one
organism per milliliter of blood
and that makes sense because if most
infections are coming from a distant
site let's say the lungs when those
organisms spill into the bloodstream
they're getting diluted you also have
phagocytic cells that are removing those
organisms so when you draw a blood
culture from a peripheral vein you're
going to have relatively few organisms
in that sample when it's collected
the next point is that for most blood
culture bottles they're under filled and
again I have seven studies that I've
quoted here and they look at the percent
of bottles that were properly filled and
we see anywhere from three percent of
the bottles are properly filled to less
than 50 percent of the bottles and this
is true whether it's a pediatric or an
adult patient
two nice Studies by by Chang and Kahari
looked at the actual average amount of
blood put into a bottle and it was right
around two and a half milliliters of
blood which is one quarter of the amount
of blood that should be processed or
that what's recommended
there's a number of studies that have
looked at what happens when you increase
the volume of blood that's cultured and
in every case as you increase the amount
of blood you culture you get more
positive blood cultures the last study
by Patel maybe is the best one to look
at and what they did is they filled
between four and six bottles each bottle
with 10 milliliters of blood and they
then said okay if we look at one bottle
compared to two bottles what is the
increase in positives and that's they
saw a 25 increase in positive blood
cultures by using two bottles properly
filled by using four bottles properly
filled there was almost a 50 percent
increase and using six bottles or three
blood cultures they had almost a 65
percent increase in positive cultures
so with all of this in mind it's
important to remember relatively few
organisms circulate in the blood of
patients with infections so we need to
collect a large volume of blood in order
to maximize the number of positive
cultures
blood culture bottles are consistently
under filled
so many cultures are going to be
negative
so we should maximize the value of blood
coaches by following a simple rule 10
milliliters of blood per bottle
two bottles per culture and a minimum of
two cultures per patient and with that
we should see more than 50 percent
increase in our positive blood cultures
and ultimately isn't that why we collect
blood cultures
the other factor to keep in mind is the
culture media and again a couple of
principles are important to keep in mind
here there's no culture meeting that
will support the growth of all organisms
resin media remove both antibiotics but
also important growth nutrients so we
have to balance the value of resin media
specialized media like pediatric fungal
and lytic media enhancer recovery and
time the detection of selected pathogens
and we always have to use a combination
of aerobic and anaerobic media
when I say no culture media supports the
growth of all organisms just think about
the simple fact that strict aerobic
organisms like pseudomonas and yeast
don't grow in the anaerobic bottle
and strict anaerobic organisms like
bacteritis don't grow in the aerobic
bottle we need a combination of media
types to enhance the overall recovery of
organisms
resin media was introduced 40 years ago
by becton Dickinson and it was
introduced to remove antibiotics present
in the blood sample
most antibiotic classes can be removed
by these resins although some extended
spectrum cephalosporins carbopenums and
other broad spectrum antibiotics can
still have activity that remains but
residents also remove nutrients
anticoagulants and other required growth
factors so when we think about a resin
media it's important to remember there's
a balance between their beneficial
effects and their harmful effects
so to say we have the most powerful
resin media is not necessarily the best
media because it could be removing more
nutrients than um than than a more
balanced resin media and with 40 years
of experience of becton Dickinson had
with repairing resin media I think
they've done a very good job balancing
the benefits and the deficits of these
uh these types of media formulations
specialized media is also important that
includes pediatric media that's
specifically designed for Pediatric
patients specialized fungal media that
enhances the both detection and time to
detection of slow growing fungic
candidate Labrada and cryptococcus
neoformons litig media releases
intracellular organisms and the lice
blood cells provide nutrients that
enhance the rate of growth of organisms
which in with the elimination of blood
cells it reduces the background of blood
cell metabolism so we see earlier
detection of organisms in specific media
and then finally there's a number of
studies that have shown the value of
anaerobic media with improved recovery
when an anaerobic bottle is combined
with an aerobic bottle and this is
primarily because the majority of
organisms that we detect in blood
cultures are facultative anaerobic
organisms that is organisms that grow
both aerobically and anaerobically
organisms like the staphylococci the
streptococci the introbacteria ACA and
we see that many of those organisms
initially prefer to grow in the
anaerobic bottle which is the reason why
the anaerobic bottle is is combined with
the aerobic bottle
so the principles of positive blood
culture is relatively few organisms
circulate in the bloodstream of the
septic patient culture and increased
volume of blood increases the likelihood
of obtaining the positive blood culture
and the use of multiple types of media
is required for an Optimum blood culture
so an important question remains how do
we optimize blood collection
um
you have to use the fastest most
effective skin disinfectants in the
table here I I have data on both
tincture of iodine and chlorhexidine
alcohol both of which are excellent
disinfectants for blood cultures the
difference though is chlorhexidine's
activity is faster and it appears to be
a bit more effective with tincture of
iodine
we should also consider the use of
standardized collection protocols as
well as collection kits to standardize
the way blood cultures are collected to
get the optimum results where possible a
dedicated phlebotomy team should be used
and critical for however blood cultures
are are collected whatever team is
collecting blood cultures is we have to
provide education
we have to provide training we have to
monitor the effectiveness of this
Education and Training and give feedback
how to improve our blood culture
techniques
we should also look for
sort of innovative approaches to doing
the standardized procedure and I just
illustrate that concept with needle
design
um in the BD Ultra touch is a thin wall
needle
that allows to allows you to collect
blood at a fader faster rate than a
traditional needle and so just a little
bit of uh calculations using the thin
wall needle which then has a larger
interior diameter for a 23 gauge needle
that provides it 40 percent increase
opening size and for a 25 gauge needle
it's a 33 percent increase
opening size for the 23 gauge needle
using the ultra touch needle released
with laboratory bench studies they've
shown that there's an 86 percent
increase rate of collecting blood and so
ultimately what you want to do is
maximize the amount of blood that goes
into the blood culture bottle and to do
that is to allow faster flow low right
into that bottle
so let me just summarize what I've the
points I've tried to make here we
recognize that each clinical situation
poses a diagnostic and an economic
challenge each patient in each hospital
setting is going to be different and
this can elimit this can limit the
availability of Diagnostics
so what I would say is the collection of
a single properly filled two bottle
blood culture is better than collection
of multiple pork quality cultures
so my my plea is to make every blood
culture that's collected optimal and if
that means you can only collect one
culture set all right maximize the value
of that one culture set
if you can collect two to three blood
culture sets maximize the value of each
one that's collected
so with that let me stop here uh and let
me turn the um the platform over to
Sarah smes and
um
maybe I have a message that I'm just
trying to say okay so Sarah I'll let you
take over
wonderful well thank you Dr Murray that
was excellent hi everyone and thank you
for your time today my name is Sarah and
I'm a vascular access nurse here in
Canada with experience both in Canada
and the US so very excited to be here
today to participate in this important
webinar
as Dr Murray explained there are many
ways in which pre-analytics can impact
the quality of a blood culture sample
and our lab teams and nurses do a great
job taking into consideration the topics
discussed previously when it comes to
venipuncture collection however specific
to nursing there are some differences
especially when accessing Central lines
which is unique to us as nurses
so we know that 70 of all clinical
decisions are based on Laboratory test
results and this is more critical for
patients with a suspected bloodstream
infection who are at risk for sepsis
however we recognize that it is hard to
maintain competencies with Staffing
shortages which all Healthcare
facilities are currently experiencing
which means you may have less capacity
for training or making sure nurses are
following standard operating procedures
and protocols
blood culture collection may not be top
of mind for your nurses depending on the
institution they're sometimes trained
and coached by more experienced peers
however training can vary with each
nurse trainer based on their skills and
preferences
peer coaches also have their own
patience and responsibilities so
training may be cut short or only cover
the basics
now Dr Murray did an excellent job
discussing the challenges of blood
culture collection the impact of the
pre-analytics on the quality of the
blood culture results and many of our
institutions have phlebotomy teams who
are experts in venipuncture blood
culture collections
from a nursing perspective what happens
if a blood culture collection from a
central venous access device is required
this is something that is unique to
nursing as phlebotomists are not
permitted to touch these lines and yet
if a clabsi is suspected we need to rule
out an infection and so this practice is
what I want to review with you all today
carefully analyze the risks versus
benefits before deciding to use
essential vascular access device for
obtaining blood samples risks associated
with sampling from a cvad include
increased Hub manipulation the potential
for intra-luminal contamination as well
as alterations in device patency
the infusion nursing Society or ins
standards state that collection from
cvads should only be performed to rule
out central line Associated bloodstream
infections or in the absence of viable
peripheral venipuncture sites all other
blood culture collections should be
performed via venipuncture
so first point as referenced earlier the
needless connector on the line has been
proven to be a high source of
contamination so even if the connector
was just changed a few hours ago please
replace the needleless connector with a
brand new sterile connector in addition
you may think that because it's brand
new you don't have to disinfect it
however let's say your gloves have
touched the needleless connector during
the change this may potentially
contaminate the sample so after the new
needless connector has been replaced
disinfect according to your facilities
policy
secondly do not discard blood prior to
the blood culture draw
if eclabsia is suspected discarding the
initial blood draw would mean losing the
blood which has been sitting in the
catheter which is most likely con to
contain pathogens
and finally never directly connect the
culture bottle to the line due to the
serious risk of a reflux of catheter
broth or medium into the catheter
this is actually the rationale behind
the clinical and laboratory standards
Institute clsi directive against direct
connection for phlebotomy blood cultures
therefore a syringe collection is
recommended for taking cultures from a
pick or other central line
at least two blood culture sets should
be obtained from a patient with a
suspected catheter-related bloodstream
infection at least one set should be
obtained from a peripheral venipuncture
and labeled as such
at approximately the same time that
peripheral set is obtained the other set
should be obtained aseptically from the
catheter Hub or through the Venus access
port septum and labeled as such
and the last point I want to highlight
about blood collection through a central
line focuses on safety I've seen this
many times and even done this myself by
attaching a lure lock syringe to the
line drawing the necessary amount of
blood and then found a way to transfer
the blood either into the blood culture
bottles or into blood tubes using a
needle using a needle for this is not
safe practice I think we all understand
this as there is a risk for needle stick
injury which is why the ins standard
States using a needleless transfer
device fill the appropriate vacuum tubes
or blood culture bottles with the
designated volume of blood in the
correct sequence
BD's back tech or skinny neck bottles
fit inside BD's blood transfer device as
seen on the image in the slide
other bottles may be too wide to fit it
will be necessary to pursue the need for
a safe transfer device with those
manufacturers
according to ins the use of vacuum tubes
or holders may not be recommended for
use on smaller cvads for example a 1.9
French or 2.6 French preferably inserted
Central catheter
the entire blood Spectrum collection
process includes multiple steps for this
training we will review the following
four steps which are preparation
collection material disposal and lastly
labeling and transport of the specimens
remember to always follow your
institution's current policies and
procedures
identify the correct patient with the
order for blood culture specimen
collection at the time of sample
collection and in the presence of the
patient use two different unique
identifiers as directed by your policy
and procedure to ensure the correct
patient is having their blood drawn this
is vitally important to ensure the
correct blood culture results align with
the correct patient do not rely on room
and bed location for patient
identification as patients may be moved
frequently in the acute care setting
provide patient education regarding the
purpose and process for blood sampling
stop all infusions as appropriate at
least one minute prior to the blood
collection
if you are using a staggered multi-lumen
sea vad withdrawal blood from the most
distal lumen always use the appropriate
Lumen as recommended by the catheter
manufacturer
looking at bottle preparation before use
ensure each blood culture bottle is free
from any sign of contamination such as
cloudiness bulging or depressed septum
or leakage keep in mind optimal fill
levels for BD backtech bottles are 8 to
10 mils for adults and one to three
meals for Pediatrics so before
collecting your bottles using the
measurement guide on the side of the BD
backtech bottle Mark the bottle with the
desired fill level a dark pen or Sharpie
works well
this way when you are in the process of
transferring the blood into the bottle
you know when you have reached the
optimal fill level
the use of a 10 mil syringe will also
help ensure that you've collected the
correct quantity of blood from the line
since blood collection is the primary
reason for this practice follow
universal precautions and wear gloves I
have seen many nurses neglect to do this
which increases the risk for blood
exposure
remove the flip off off cap from the
bottle tops and disinfect the rubber
septum with alcohol this step will
prevent contaminants from entering the
bottle during collection caution here on
not using povidone iodine since it
corrodes the septum
finally allow the alcohol to fully dry
before puncturing the septum once
collection has been initiated
next as discussed earlier you will
remove and discard the used needless
connector prior to drawing a blood
sample to do this first disinfect the
connection surface and size of the
existing needle-free connector and the
catheter hub for 5 to 15 seconds with
isopropyl alcohol or for chlorhexidine
gluconate according to the
manufacturer's instructions for use
remove the connector and clean the
outside of the catheter hub using the
same process be sure to let it dry if it
is not dry when the new sterile
connector is applied it may Bond the
connector to the catheter Hub making it
more difficult to remove
dry times are five seconds for isopropyl
alcohol and 20 seconds for chlorhexidine
gluconate on a device
apply a new sterile needless connector
and disinfect according to your
facility's internal protocol and allowed
to fully dry
now on to the actual blood collection
using a sterile 10 mil syringe attach
The Lure lock syringe to the line using
aseptic technique and collect 8 to 10
mils of blood for each bottle and one to
three mils for Pediatric bottles for
Pediatric collections also ensure you
refer to your internal protocol as the
required volume collected may be based
on patient body weight
once you have drawn the correct amount
of blood disconnect from the line and
insert the syringe tip into the BD
vacutainer blood transfer device and
turn clockwise to secure
place the blood transfer device with the
syringe attached over the top of the
blood culture vial and puncture septum
to allow blood to transfer into the
aerobic vial
this process ensures that you are safely
transferring the blood into the blood
culture bottle with no risk of needle
stick injury
bottles should be inverted gently
several times to prevent clotting
repeat these collection steps with a new
sterile syringe and blood transfer
device and transfer the collected sample
to the anaerobic vial ensuring no air
bubbles enter vile
if other blood work needs to be drawn in
addition to cultures obtain blood
samples using the appropriate order of
draw to prevent carryover of additives
between collection tubes most
importantly blood culture bottles should
always be collected first
finally flush the cvat according to
internal protocol using a pulsatile push
pause technique minimizes buildup of
residue from medications or fibrin this
technique creates a turbulent flush that
helps clear the sides as well as the
center of the catheter
ensuring the line is free of blood
following specimen collection is
critical to ensure the catheter remains
patent for future use and reduces the
risk of occlusion related complications
once collection is complete dispose of
the syringes and blood transfer devices
and the nearest Sharps container dispose
of all used materials such as gloves
appropriately and wash hands
label appropriately with required
information including the date and time
of collection specific Central Venus
access device used for collection and
volume of blood collected immediately
after the phlebotomy and in the
patient's presence be cautious not to
cover the barcode with stickers or
writing as it is used by the instrument
to process the specimen
also do not cover the bottom of the
bottle as it is monitored for
microorganism growth
follow your policy and procedure for
documentation but typical information
included in the patient's health record
includes the date and the time of the
phlebotomy the root and specific vad or
Lumen used
the amount of blood withdrawn in
specific laboratory tests
vad flushing and locking patient
response to the procedure as well as the
education that you provided to the
patient
lastly transport bottles to the lab in a
closed leak-proof biohazard container as
soon as possible any delays in entering
blood culture bottles into the
continuous monitoring blood culture
instruments May delay or impede
detection of growth
remember that blood culture bottles
should never be refrigerated or frozen
after collection as this can kill the
microorganisms
I hope this presentation has informed
your practice in a meaningful way and
perhaps clarified questions you may have
had regarding blood culture collection
from a nursing perspective thank you for
your time and for any additional
information or to learn more about BD's
clinical and educational services please
contact your local BD representative
and I'll hand it back over
excellent well thank you Dr Murray and
thank you Sarah for your informative
informative presentations
so we have time for a couple of
questions so if you have any question
you'd like to ask please do so now as I
mentioned earlier you just click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
and we will answer them
[Music]
so let's see
so we have a few questions here so the
first question is for Dr Murray
um so for venue puncture collections
can the type of wing set selected have
an impact on field volumes
so I think it's important to go go back
to one of the comments I made right at
the end of my presentation and that is
the fill volume is going to be in large
part determined by how long the the
venipuncture collection kit is in
contact with a bottle itself
and so
needle design where the inner Lumen is
larger than a conventional needle
is going to allow a faster fill
per unit of time and so yes it does make
a difference what type of a wing set is
used and and that was really the reason
why BD developed the ultra touch needle
design for for collection of blood
excellent thank you
um well another one for Dr Murray so you
mentioned
um a specialized media uh earlier in
your presentation so are all blood
culture uh vendors media's equivalent
especially for Pediatric media you know
each each company's media is
um proprietary
and the design of the media is what they
think is going to be Optimum for
Recovery of organisms
um I think it's very important to look
at the formulations of media and in some
cases it's revealing you specifically
mentioned or the the person to pose the
question specifically mentioned
pediatric media
I think it's important to remember that
um just because
a small volume of media is put into a
bottle and called pediatric does that
mean it's specifically designed for
Pediatric patients
so the at least to my knowledge now and
this may have changed but I don't think
it has the bu Marry You pediatric media
is the same media that's used in adult
bottles just with a smaller volume uh
when Becca Dickinson developed their
pediatric media was with pediatric
patients specifically in mine
particularly organisms like hemophilus
to optimize the recovery of of those
types of organisms
um I think uh the same thing could be
said about fungal media that's um uh
that's available again specific
formulations that are designed to
optimize recovery of fungi I believe BD
is the only company that has litig media
which I actually think is the best media
that's currently available in the market
and then finally the resin media uh both
view mirror you and Victor Dickinson
make that they use different
concentrations of resins in their
bottles and different media formulations
of supplements for those bottles so
again there are differences there and in
the case of residence media I I would
again emphasize
um you have to look at the overall
recovery of organisms in those bottles
and not just say which bottle is the
most effective in removing antibiotics
because the most powerful resins for
removing antibiotics aren't necessarily
the best for a blood culture bottle
so there are differences
thank you
um now one question for Sarah
so uh our facility uses non-bd bottles
and so when transferring line
collections with a syringe
we currently use the blunt fill needle
you showed during your your presentation
which is certainly risky practice have
you found a blood transfer device that
fits
um The Wider non-beaty bottles
hmm
a great question
um I am most familiar with the BD
products and the BD backtech bottles as
well as that transfer device so I'm not
aware but I would really check with that
manufacturer and see if they have a safe
alternative to using a needle for that
transfer practice
um I mean that being said I know with
with BD we have everything that the full
solution for blood collection blood
culture results from the transfer device
as well as the instrument all the way to
the patient results so it's got that
full spectrum and that's that's my
knowledge so I would say I would just
really focus on on transferring with a
transfer device instead of using that
needle in an potentially unsafe way
excellent thank you
um
let me check here so we have a comment
here about uh saying thank you Dr Marie
and Sarah for this excellent uh
presentation
um and they were asking if we can share
uh the presentations
um with the staff so just so you know
for your information
um this
presentation will be available on this
site for one year
um and you feel free to connect contact
your BD representative uh as they will
also be able to support your hospital
with further education as well for your
nursing staff or your lab staff
um
so with the interest of time uh I'm
gonna wrap this up
so
um
on behalf of BD thank you again Dr
Murray and Sarah for your time today and
your important work
um we would also like to thank labroos
for organizing today's educational
webcast
so before we go I'd also like to thank
the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions uh so questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
uh during the Andaman period will be
addressed by uh the speaker uh the
speakers via the the um
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
so I'm seeing a couple of questions
coming in
um still so those questions will be
addressed and answered don't worry about
that
so this webcasts can be viewed on demand
so lab routes will alert you uh via
email when it's available for replay so
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's Live Events so again on behalf
of BD thank you for attending
um so take care everyone and goodbye